I'm joined in the studio by Nick vergon
welcome good to be here yes thank you
Nick you serve as executive uh vice
president yes if I'm not mistaken and
chief marketing and Communications
officer for Ascension please tell us
more about Ascension and what is your
role there we are the nation's largest
non-profit Catholic Health Care System
we're based here in St Louis and I
oversee our marketing and about eight or
nine years ago I reached out to Rick
singfield and said how can we help heal
North St Louis County in the Ferguson
area and we came up with a nonprofit
called your move chess which is really
about creating more access at the
Scholastic level and you know Rex has
been committed to that in the chess club
and so it funds all the after-school
chess and Ferguson and I fell in love
with the game about 10 years ago my wife
played and she taught my son and I
learned at the same time and I believe
that chess is an amazing game to help
create life skills for children to
reinforce the love of learning
particularly math and music there's a
lot of similarities and it's something
that you can play for life it's just
amazing families play together my family
plays together and so I'm so proud in St
Louis that we thanks to Rex and his
vision we've become the epicenter of
global chess here and that's something
that our community as a community leader
we take enormous pride in
while and I have an exclusive piece of
information that you're an avid chess
player yourself you love chess and you
follow uh videos on YouTube I do so I'm
a big big Daniel nardinsky fan his speed
run so I started watching that a couple
years ago and I've improved my chess.com
rating from about 1400 to 1800 and so my
wife jokes that I spend more time with
him than I do her watching him and I
love watching Eric Hanson who's a good
friend and John Bartholomew and I think
you know part of what St Louis has done
and and the chess club and wrecks and
his vision is created this ecosystem
where people could stream now you know
10 years ago five years ago that didn't
exist and now with Cara was one of the
biggest streamers uh Magnus is streaming
you have people like Daniel and John
Bartholomew and the chess bras and it's
helped create this ecosystem of Chess
that is not only transforming St Louis
but really I mean chess has boomed over
the last few years and I think St Louis
and the chess club and Rex and his
vision and what he's done has helped
spur that
I did and well I think that you also
have your own YouTube channel I do you
know a couple months ago I'm a historian
by Nature I've written five books and I
started a YouTube channel uh about
history and so my brother and I and
we've created over 100 films in the last
month and a half two months we have a
hundred thousand views a thousand Subs
if you go to Nick Lagoon on YouTube and
it's really about telling stories and at
some point I'm going to do something on
Bobby Fisher maybe Fisher spots again I
know we had a great exhibit here on uh
at the Chess Hall of Fame on on 72 in
the world championship and I love
telling stories and I think uh the chess
story particularly during the Cold War
era when chess was a proxy for you know
the larger battle between East and West
as you know uh telling that story and so
I'm looking forward on my YouTube
channel at some point and I want to
interview Rex which I think would be
amazing but I wanted to and he's met
Bobby Fisher I want to tell that story
uh to introduce it to younger kids who
play chess who don't know who Bobby
Fischer was or they don't know in 1972
how chess for a couple months during the
summer was the most watched thing on the
planet and I just think that's an
amazing moment in time well I don't know
if you know it's but that's something
you shared with Daniel noraditski so I
hope that he's watching your YouTube
channel and I couldn't help but notice
that you have this Ascension Charity
Classic I know that Ascension is the big
supporter of Saint Louis chess program
but tell me a little bit about what is
this sure it's our golf tournament our
PGA Tour event at Norwood we created it
three years ago again similar to when we
created your move chest in North St
Louis County it was about taking a sport
professional golf that isn't really
known for being diverse and inclusive
putting it in the Ferguson area in North
St Louis County and taking all the
proceeds and putting it back into
charity so in this case the Boys and
Girls Club Urban League Mary Grove and
growing the game of golf in North St
Louis County and so we're going up on
our third year and I'm proud to say it's
the most attended event on PGA Tour
Champions it's the most profitable and
in year two now it's already the most
charitable we gave away 1.3 million
dollars last year two million dollars
overall and I'm enormously proud that in
a couple short years golf professional
golf now is driving charitable donations
and making the game more diverse and
inclusive and and I took a lot of the
inspiration of creating that from what
Rex has done with chess here and
building an ecosystem that's about
giving back to the community
yes this is a wonderful initiative and I
assume you play golf I play golf I'm
probably better at chess now than I am a
golf if I was uh as good at golf as
chess I'd be happy but my enthusiasm
outpaces my skill that's a very
important quality to have uh could you
compare those two games yeah they're
both strategy based you know they're
both about thinking moves ahead I mean
chess is clearly about strategy right
and calculating golf is very similar
it's it's it's a marathon not a Sprint
you're thinking ahead and you're
thinking about where to place the ball
and and how to compete and I think
there's a lot of life lessons to be
involved with chess if you're younger
you learn how to plan and you make
decisions and strategize and decisions
have consequences golf is very similar
and in fact I sit on the board of first
tea which is an organization that
introduces golf to young kids
particularly in underserved areas and I
think chess and golf are two life skills
if you're a younger kid that you could
take with you forever you could play it
forever and it's also good you know if
you become a business person you need to
know how to play golf and if you're uh
if you learn how to play chess it's
something you can do for your whole life
thank you very much I have one last
question I know that you follow the
tournaments every day who is your
favorite to win this tournament you know
I'm curious to see if Anna could hold on
I think having an I am win would be a
big deal I'm sure she'd get a GM Norm uh
and so I think you know with humping
withdrawing it changes a little bit but
I'm room for for her I'd love to I think
it'd be great for the game to have an IM
win a tournament that's predominantly
GM's and I've loved watching the action
I just think it's fantastic and I think
the Karen's cup has become in a short
amount of time the premiere event it is
a real Landmark on the chest scene thank
you very much this was a very insightful
interview thank you for having me thank
you Nick very